como se ve en los medios de comunicación
iraníes el cuerpo del principal
científico nuclear de irán fue llevado
en procesión al santuario de iman resta
uno de los varios lugares sagrados
chiítas a los que fueron llevados sus
restos antes de ser enterrado este lunes
mosén fakhri shade fue asesinado a tiros
por desconocidos el viernes mientras
conducía por teherán apodado el padre
del programa nuclear iraní por israel
irán culpa de su muerte a los israelíes
actuando como mercenarios para eeuu el
parlamento iraní prometió el domingo
vengarse votando revisar y probablemente
reducir la cooperación del país con el
organismo internacional de energía
atómica y la responsabilidad de todas
las fuerzas y organizaciones
relacionadas es convertir la amenaza de
esta lamentable pérdida en una
oportunidad para fortalecernos en los
ámbitos económicos de seguridad defensa
y nuclear la oea y los socios europeos
han estado luchando por salvar el
acuerdo nuclear de irán de 2015 que
alivió las sanciones occidentales a la
república islámica a cambio de que el
país frenará su programa de armas
nuclear
donald fue al retiro a eeuu del acuerdo
en 2018 en su lugar optó por nuevas
sanciones más duras en una campaña
llamada presión máxima campaña a la que
teherán ha respondido abandonando
gradualmente sus compromisos nucleares
el presidente electo de eeuu joe biden
ha señalado su voluntad de volver a
unirse al acuerdo pero ahora contra anv
a punto de dejar el cargo en enero el
asesinato de fac trisha de ha renovado
la oposición iraní y podría dificultar
la opción de bailén de revivir el
acuerdo también planea la preocupante
posibilidad de una confrontación militar
abierta entre eeuu e irán en las últimas
semanas de la administración trump